Titan southerners largest moon and in fact the second largest moon in the solar
system after Ganymede isn't amazing and mysterious world of its own being larger
in fact and the planet mercury,
it's often seen as a planetary moon.
What's interesting though is a titan is the only moon in the solar system with a
dense atmosphere so dense in fact,
that if a human were to strap on wings,
they could take off flying.
It is also the only other body in the solar system besides earth,
with bodies of liquids on surface,
so tied in a large rocky body with a dense atmosphere and rainfall that feeds
lakes and rivers.
When scientists first really begin to observe the moon,
they were struck by its similarity to earth.
What's missing life of course,
or is it this striking similarity to places on earth and the fact that we still
have yet to properly examine tighten means many scientists are speculating that
life on titan could be possible,
but there's a problem.
Titan's surface temperature is negative 179 degrees Celsius or negative 290
degrees Fahrenheit.
Accordingly,
the liquid on titans,
not water.
It's methane,
which is a gas here on earth.
To answer the question of whether or not life on Titan could exist,
you must ask cause methane replace water as a solvent and alien life.
Well,
many scientists have doubts for why is water such a good elixir of life?
it comes down to the atomic level.
Water is h two o meaning an oxygen atom with two hydrogen atoms.
This means one side of the molecule is positively charged and the other side is
negatively charged.
Why is that important?
Well,
this polarity helps water dissolves things and mixed them up in this works
especially well with carbon based life forms like you and me and every living
organism on this planet.
Assuming of course you are a carbon based life form an alien,
and by the way,
scientists are skeptical of life forms that are not carbon based,
such as silicon based life forms,
but anyway,
methane,
however is c h for a carbon atom accompanied by four hydrogen atoms.
Accordingly,
it's not polar like water is and can't dissolve things.
That living organism would need into a soup quite as well.
Basically the current understanding of life doesn't make it seem very likely,
but our current understanding of life is based off only one example.
Therefore,
life on Titan would have to exist in a way that we don't yet fully understand.
Finding it there with not only revolutionize our understanding of biology by the
discovery of alien life,
but it would open the door to an even greater and more diverse range of life
forms in the universe if our carbon and water loving selves,
we're not the only kind of life around.
And so when are we going back to Titan?
Well,
NASA and the European Space Agency proposed a mission called the t s s m a titan
Saturn system mission,
which would have included a hot air balloon and a lander on Titan.
But in 2009 and Jupiter mission wasn't given precedence over this mission and a
Saturn mission was set back.
If you're ready to visit Titan to find out about life,
be sure to like this video and for more videos on many other core subjects,
including alien life,
be sure to check out fire learning and subscribe.
Thank you for watching.